Welcome to the first ever
online Wiesner Gallery Tour.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe,
and I'm the manager of
the student arts programs
here at MIT.
I'm also joined by
Sarah Hirzel, who
is the coordinator of the
Wiesner Student Art Gallery
and Dalma Foldesi
and Jung In Seo,
both graduates of the MIT School
of Architecture and Planning
master's degree, and
they were class of 2020.
Congratulations.
This evening, we're
pleased for them
to present their exhibition
called Misalignments.
It's a multipart exploration
of materiality and fabrication,
both by machine and by hand.
Dalma and Jung
examined how robots
are affecting the texture
of our built environment
and demonstrate
through their work
some ways that they might
subvert those trends.
After a brief introduction by
Sarah about the exhibition,
Dalma and Jung will lead us
through their virtual show
via screen share.
Without further ado, I'm going
to pass it over to Sarah.
My name is Sarah Hirzel.
I'm the coordinator of the
Wiesner Student Art Gallery,
which is a space open
to any art practitioners
in any medium from any part
of MIT who are currently
enrolled us students.
So keep that in mind if you're
interested in pursuing any kind
of project of this kind.
Back on March 11, I
was really excited,
because Dalma and Jung
were busy installing
a show in the Wiesner Gallery
in W20 in the student center.
We were going to have an
opening the following week.
They had plans for
an installation
with custom-made podiums.
They were going to
shape the walls all
to support really exquisite work
that you're going to see here.
The show was halfway built
when we were sent home
by the Institute.
And though it's
really disappointing
that we can't share these really
subtle and beautiful pieces
with all of you in
person, I could not
be more thrilled with
the way that they
transformed that exhibition
into this opportunity.
And I think that the site
that they made as a gallery
really illuminates their
research, their process,
and their vision for all of us.
As you'll see, these two
architect artists are--
they are unusually
well suited to bridge
the gap between the handmade
or the in-person experience
and the mechanized
world of technology.
They were the perfect candidates
for this to solve this problem.
So leave it to them to
take our expectations
and turn them upside down.
I'm really grateful
that they're here
to help us re-envision
what the Wiesner can
be right now at this moment.
So without further
ado, I just would
like to introduce Jung
In Seo and Dalma Foldesi.
And I'd like to begin
by asking the two of you
to share a really basic
introduction to what you
do in layman's terms,
especially for people who've
never seen your work before.
Thank you for the introductions,
Shannon Rose and Sarah.
I'm Dalma.
And I'm Jung.
Thank you for joining us today.
We're really excited
for this opportunity.
And what we're
showing you today is
grounded in the work that began
as part of our master's thesis
at MIT.
We reformatted it for
this virtual show,
and we're very
much honored to be
part of the Arts on the Radar.
And so the
thank-yous-- we really
want to thank everyone who
helped make this possible.
So huge thank-you to Sarah,
Lydia, Andrea, and Heidi
from Arts at MIT and also to our
advisors, who are not here yet,
I don't think, Mariana,
Axel, and Mark.
And then also to the
ceramics studios at MIT--
so Daryl, Jay, and thank you,
Graham, who's here also today.
And also at Harvard,
Nathan, Kathy, Jeff, Kyle,
and Casey, who
were super helpful.
And last, the
fabrication team at MIT
Architecture-- so Chris, Jen,
Shah, Zane, Jay, and Jeff.
Thank you so much for
making this possible.
And I think with that, we
might attempt screen share
and see how that goes.
First, a few words about the
design of the gallery itself
where you are
interested in exploring
what this virtual
format can afford us
given the scale and
materiality of our work
and the time-based media
that comes along with it.
So we decided to go against
this one-dimensional experience
based on scrolling and image
and image grid layouts.
But we also didn't want to
go in the other direction
where we create a game-like
3D environment in the browser.
Yeah.
So instead, what follows is
a series of rooms, for those
of you who haven't been there.
It's sort of
skeuomorphic and familiar
in the way it's constructed
and its first impression.
But later, it becomes
defamiliarized
as you begin to explore
the spaces a bit more.
And we focused on this
non-linear exploration
of the galleries and
layering information
in the design of the UI,
the user interaction.
And much like in
physical galleries,
at first you're immersed
in this full screen image.
And later, you can
sort of uncover
details and nested
layers of information.
And I think with that, we
can walk into the first room.
Yeah, so our title,
Misalignment,
is discussed in this first room.
And our interest is in the
conditions of misalignments
that are usually emerging
around the imprecise material
assemblies and engineering.
The title brings
us to the question
of exactitude and
ideal geometries, which
we specifically
wanted to interrogate
within the discipline
of architecture.
And to delve into that
a little bit more,
we wanted to use the example
of these standard sized bricks.
The example of bricks and the
history of the mechanization
of their production introduces
some of the key concepts
that this exhibition
works to destabilize.
So in the development
of brick-making machines
in the US, which happened
throughout the 19th century,
this material, clay,
was controlled and made
to conform to these
ideal orthogonal,
preconceived geometries
of a certain size.
Yeah.
Ironically though,
these actions that
produced these precise
geometries were quite simple.
They had to rely
on this simplicity.
In this case, pressing
clay into a wooden box
to reproduce the standardized
dimensions within tolerance.
These low fidelity
actions, as we're
going to start calling
them, almost mechanical,
produce high
dimensional stability
by which we mean that the
final brick conformed to the 2
by 4 by 6--
that kind of
dimensions that they
required in standardized parts.
So here, the quote that
you see kind of also
explains that as
men were molders
who would scoop up enough clay
for about a brick and a half,
press it firmly into a
sand-sprinkled wooden box,
divide into
brick-sized sections,
and then scrape off
any excess material.
So it's a very low fidelity,
simple action that you would
have to perform repetitively.
Can you all see the screen OK?
Works fine.
Cool.
So--
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so-- oh, sorry.
You were going to go.
I mean, the more or
less exact diagram
that we show here expands
this notion of exactness based
on the two criteria that
we mentioned before,
one that is based on
the analysis of fidelity
of actions versus the
dimensional stability.
The first axis,
the vertical axis,
locates the exactness in
the dimensional stability.
How closely can you realize
some preconceived ideal geometry
within tolerance?
Typical of Western architecture
practices, these buildings that
follow this model are
designed to approximate some
very ideal geometries
drawn in plan and sections
through cycles of building
and then also correction,
decay, maintenance,
and restoration.
Yes, so this is the first
sort of vertical axis
that you see here.
And on the other
hand, this horizontal
axis that we're introducing
sort of understands exactness
in terms of the fidelity
of gestures as opposed
to dimensions.
This is the fidelity of actions.
And for example, in vernacular
mud and clay construction,
the objective is not to
achieve some preconceived ideal
geometry and
dimensions, but rather
to find a form through layers
of carefully performed actions.
Even though these actions may
not seem dimensionally precise
per se, these builders have
a very fine-tuned sensibility
to the material that
they are working with.
And their actions are
precise in that term.
These precise actions
allow the thin structures
to stand and not collapse.
And in doing so, they
better adapt to the material
availability and accommodate
material qualities,
sometimes letting the
material qualities to emerge
rather than suppressing it.
And so throughout this
show, we're kind of also
working within this diagram
but different from what
contemporary digital
fabrication projects tend to do,
which tend to still
inhabit the first axis.
And designers evaluate
tools and designs
based almost solely on
dimensional stability.
And they still aim to find
ever final layers, for example,
in 3D-printed buildings, almost
dematerializing those buildings
into pure geometries.
And this is often at
the expense of resources
or overlooking
material qualities
that we hope to recover.
Yeah.
And instead what
we want to explore
is how do we expand the spectrum
afforded by this diagram?
What does it mean?
Like, what if, instead of
optimizing dimensions or even
actions, we wandered
into this space?
More and more-- and sometimes
you start and more and more,
and you go into this
other zone of the diagram.
What does it mean to wander
in this space as opposed
to always trying to optimize,
always going into the finer
and finer precision?
Can we think of
design as trajectories
rather than goal product
fixed in time and space?
So these are the questions that
we are revisiting in every room
essentially in different scales.
And so in really basic
terms, our project
deals with these
questions of tolerance.
And we were using this
industrial robotic arm
and our own hand gestures.
And we were trying to expand
this definition of exactness.
This will come up.
It's something that's a more--
that would admit more error
in error-prone processes.
Mm-hmm.
And we fabricated all the
objects in the exhibition
either by hand or
with this KUKA KR
6 R900 industrial
robotic arm that
sits at the MIT
architecture department.
But these arms have proliferated
in various design departments
across the country,
diverting them
from their original
roles in manufacturing.
And while they were designed
to perform precise and complex
actions in a loop, designers
now push these robots
to go beyond this original aim
of optimizing and accelerating
manufacturing.
Yet still, many
of these practices
still follow the first axis
of dimensional stability--
so getting something to fit
that prescribed dimension
as a model.
And they often obscure
the interventions
of the hand to create this
illusion of total automation.
Yeah.
So we want to kind of propose
a different approach that
celebrates this interaction
between mechanical actions
and hand gestures.
Sorry.
We developed machines and tools
to collaborate with these arms
rather than trying to
always depend on the arm.
We adopted traditional trimming
and carving tools as well as
creating custom nozzles
and custom machines,
even though they were kind
of rudimentary in the actions
that it performs.
These low tolerance machines
accommodates high tolerance
gestures and forms.
We learned from existing
open source extruder designs
and from the craft of
traditional ceramics together.
And we decided to design our own
tools to expand and understand
our design space.
Mm-hmm.
So now we're going to be
entering the next room.
So we'll get to see
these machines at work.
So this next room we
call the room of actions.
This room gives you
a glimpse or maybe
a preview of some
of the emerging
complex formal language of
these actions that we explored.
And they kind of work with the--
I mean, traditional
pottery techniques
of coiling and carving
or even stacking clay.
And so, for example,
these white coils
here illustrate this behavior
of rope coiling, which
is a behavior that other
non-Newtonian fluids also
perform when extruded--
so even glass or honey.
And like honey dribbling,
these extruded coils
fold, swirl, and
then slowly solidify
into a seemingly precarious
form deviating heavily
from the ideal,
preconceived form,
but still finding
stability in the end.
So also I think we
have some images
of the process and the
nozzles that we designed.
And we'll get back to seeing
this in action in a bit.
And one other example we wanted
to bring up is the carving.
The carving is kind
of a risky balancing
act between material behavior
and prescribed geometry,
because the carving action
removes the excess material
created by coiling.
And it, in a way, gets closer
to the original prescribed form.
Or sometimes, depending on the
tolerances of the coiled form,
it can make a very dramatic
puncture such as this opening.
So this was the
tool that we used
to carve this form
where we began
with this layer
of coiling actions
that varies on the tolerances.
And as a result, when you
carve away from this form,
at some locations you get
this very uniform surface
qualities, where in
these other cases where,
because of the low tolerances
of the surface that
was developed before, this
creates a very dramatic
opening.
Mm-hmm.
So it's about calibrating
those openings,
and even though not determining
their size precisely.
And in order to get--
and we'll let you explore
some of the other things
in this room later on.
But to get here to these
sort of complex textures
and layered actions, we first
mapped out the expanded space
off the diagram to create
a series of objects
that we called
experiments, which you see
in this room on this platform.
So on this platform
here, the experiments
populate the diagram that
you saw in the first room.
And by fixing the ideal geometry
with these torqued ellipses,
we were able to map out
the different qualities
and textures and forms and
behaviors at the edges--
at all of the edges and in
the middle of this diagram.
And you see the lower left, from
collapsing into the formless
in the upper right corner to
minimal, almost imperceptible
layers that we would normally
define as exact under I
guess the axis of
dimensional stability.
We kind of explored
this full space.
And throughout that
creation, these objects
are not really fixed
in a particular form.
They can travel in this diagram
as long as they're kept moist
and they are not fired.
And sometimes they
can suddenly collapse,
or you can even
carve away from them.
So as they go further away from
a certain degree of exactness,
they can also come back to it.
So tolerance is also
change over time.
So these are just some examples.
Yeah.
Also in this gallery, we
wanted to reveal something
about the process of
creating this exhibition.
In order to bring our
objects into virtual spaces,
we actually had to create
digital copies of all of them.
Exposing this
digital materiality
was something that
we thought it was
interesting to expose the
underside of it, so to speak.
So this is essentially
what's called a texture map.
So this is a square
image that locates
pixels of the scanned
mesh that you see earlier
to give it some imitation
or appearance of, like,
giving it a texture
that's lifelike texture.
And here we were
interested in this idea
of digital materiality
showing through
and how that relates to this
digital virtual exhibition
and how it gives
it the materiality.
And it's sort of one
attempt at flattening
these three-dimensional
objects here
and also gives you a
peek at the construction
of the gallery itself.
Mm-hmm.
And from this room
of experiments,
we go over to the
room of studies,
which builds on the experiments,
similar to the details
that you saw earlier.
This moves beyond
those single actions
and imbues those actions
with intention and layers
them to create more
complex expressions.
So for example, this vault
here uses precise angles
to build an enclosure without
any additional support.
And first it's coiled with
a nozzle at specific angles
to construct the
walls, and then carving
can create openings and remove
some of the excess material.
Yeah.
And in this example, we
wanted to exploit the idea
of gradients and stability.
So where we began
on the bottom, we
add very fine layers,
almost imperceptible.
And we increased-- we
modulated the layer height
so that we get this
change in the material
behavior in the middle
and then retracting back
to this original condition.
And this is kind of going
beyond our initial studies
where we were fixing
this kind of parameters.
Now we're playing
with these parameters
to see what kind of
qualities we can get out of.
Yeah, and maybe last, this
other object kind of improvised.
We were interested in
hybridizing more explicitly
both hand and machine action.
So the first layer, the
bottom of this vault
was hand constructed
and 3D scanned.
So it sort of went
back and forth
between the digital and the
actual physical construction.
And based on those
first couple layers,
we then found a form that
would create this enclosure
and slowly built it.
And we invite you to explore
all these other objects
in this room.
Mm-hmm.
Here, if the earlier room where
we discussed about the texture
maps was one kind of
flattening the scan meshes,
this room presents
another way to capture
in two dimensions the
tool path and the actions
by the bare hands.
These two are
radically different,
like one that's seemingly
very organized and regular,
and there's this other layer
where it seems very chaotic.
These are collaborative in a way
that they reveal the hands that
assists and adjusts
designs with and sometimes
altering the planned path.
Even if they're
different, these two paths
are very much coordinated.
They are traces in a
different sense than what
we had discussed earlier.
They don't draw the
final object per se,
but they show the dialogue of
the mechanical and mathematical
movements of the tool and
organic gestures of the hand.
Yeah, and while
this room, I think,
captures these
actions frozen in time
and flattened out on these
surfaces, the next room
and the final room that
we'll show you today
shows the machines and the
hand in action in time.
So this is a little video room.
And this might be sort of slow
and jagged over our really slow
internet connection.
But we'll try to play it.
And I think I didn't
hit Optimize for Video.
So I could also just
restart the screen share.
But this might be
a good point for us
to stop and let the video
speak for themselves
and open up for Q&A.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you all so much
for coming out here.
I am just curious
your conception
about how this research is
scalable to architecture--
if you see this work as ending
in the theoretical space
or an art object that
contains an idea,
or if you think that
a robotic fabrication
of this type of material could
be done at a larger scale.
I think there are attempts
now that are being--
in the media.
For example, like, the Mars
project that they put it into,
like, discussions before.
Mm-hmm.
Where there are attempts
to go at a bigger scale
of this technology itself.
But what I think we are
missing at the point is,
again, this expanded
understanding
of why we need to be
always so precise.
And can we go beyond this narrow
perception of the exactness?
And I think in that sense, that
question exists in any scale
that we were working with.
But we would love to try
this at a larger scale.
In fact, we are
trying to discuss it.
Well, I think-- yeah, I think we
discussed this a lot of times,
both with the different build
spaces that we've been in
and especially for this virtual
exhibition where we could have
easily made a larger inhabitable
structure of the same things
that we've been working on
just by using the scans.
I mean, scale is
definitely something
that we could play with
in a virtual setting.
But we sort of naturally
moved away from that,
because I think--
yeah, I think while we would
be interested in maybe scaling
them, but it would be a very
different outcome from what you
see in this particular show.
I think we would definitely
have to rethink a lot of things,
not just forms, but even
what we're contributing
to that discussion beyond.
And I think these
objects even might
be scalable as wall sections
or something like that.
I think what we're trying
to think more about next
is more about interaction
with the machine
rather than making a
building out of this.
Yeah, because each
project that we-- like,
that two different
trajectories of our project
takes a different amount
of time in terms of,
like, what we can achieve.
Like, if we were to
go big right now,
then we would have to
dedicate a lot of time just
to scale things up
without really exploring
further questions about it.
So right now I
think, as Dalma said,
our next interest is in
the interactive part.
Tiandra has a question.
What did you find
most compelling
about the virtual
exhibition that
may not have manifested in
the original physical version?
I think-- hmm.
Hi, Tiandra.
[LAUGHS]
Thank you for the questions.
Yeah, I think one thing--
I guess one thing I
mentioned that we didn't do
is scale up and use that idea
of scaling for these objects.
One thing that we played
with was that non-linear way
of exploring and
preventing people
from going backwards, which
sort of gives these limitations,
but also, like, unique
ways of exploring
these different galleries.
And I think just setting up
a very conventional gallery
setting, which is not at
all what these objects--
like, something that these
objects speak against
is also an interesting
part of it.
Yeah.
I mean, one of our meta goal
was to think about, yes,
like, if you're doing this
in virtual exhibition,
what can we get out
of this, playing
with this virtual
exhibition as a format?
And you might have noticed
that the gravity doesn't
hold true in this
virtual exhibition
anymore as you walk through
a couple of different rooms.
So that was, like,
one cute foray
into what are the bigger
questions that we can ask.
And like, how do we
represent drawings?
How do we represent models?
And, like, the 3D scan became
a big protagonist in this
where it became--
it gave us this idea of,
like, digital materiality
where you have to jump through
a lot of loops of documenting it
in 3D scans that
we didn't think of.
And that's kind of already a
part of our process anyways.
Yeah.
Because we're always
going back and forth
between the physical and
the virtual even though
it seems more physical.
Like, when we
carve an object, we
would need to have a
scan of it in order
to be able to
carve it or perform
any other actions on them.
So that was interesting.
Mm-hmm.
We have another question.
Oh, yeah.
It looks like Graham
has his hand raised.
I do.
I really enjoyed
how you found value
in all the different
output in this project.
So whether it was
the experiments
getting their own room or
translating the 3D scan to a 2D
image or the tool paths, your
ability to find importance
or to see what each of
these steps had to offer
was really inspiring.
The process of your process
is just exciting to me.
And so I want to
commend you on that.
I would love to hear you talk
about the seam in each of the--
not so much in this
shot, but the video that
was playing prior to this, the
tool pathing will go to a point
and then change direction and go
back and then change direction.
So it goes
counterclockwise, clockwise.
And in each of the experiments,
there's a distinct seam.
Cue it up.
Look at that.
Could you just talk about what
its role in the project was?
And I will mute and
listen to your response.
Yeah.
I think it was a
big question for us
that we never really ever
talked about, I don't think.
But normally people try
to not have a seam at all.
They would just go in circles
and, like, slightly step up
maybe just like a really
small gradient all the way.
So it just seems like one
continuous coiled thing.
And I guess if you're minimizing
the layers, then it's, like,
completely--
it's not noticeable at all.
And we wanted to play with
openings though, and especially
with something
that would support
the weight of a
clay on top of it
like in this case where it's
becoming this crazy opening
here, not necessarily to make
a door or anything like that,
but just to see if we
could use this really
unstable way of making--
like closing up that seam.
And the seam actually kind
of goes around the object.
So it kind of
defines its own path.
Yeah.
And also in the--
I wanted to show--
I think we need to let--
a bit slow now.
Yeah.
In the example in the
experiments, the seam
itself helps to give
it a directionality
between each layer.
So some of them the beaded--
we call beaded
one is essentially
done by pausing after every
few seconds or something.
And so because of
that, if you go
in one direction for
one there and then
the other direction
for other layer, then
you get this alternating effect.
It's maybe not so
visible in this one.
Mm-hmm.
But for example, there.
Was this done on
the same direction?
So, like, there were--
by introducing this,
like, unstable condition,
we actually opened up a lot
of different possibilities
rather than just giving
you a vase-like form.
Can't go back now.
[LAUGHTER]
Can't go back.
So that was one
of our intentions
in introducing the seam.
And plus, like, it gives
us a challenge of how
do we make this
structural, like,
if you can't rely on
this being a closed form.
I think you can see it inside
here, but not the best view.
[LAUGHS]
Close.
For me, it acts as a
invitation since the form
isn't closed or closed in
a traditional sort of sense
where you would go
in through the top.
It acts-- like, as
a viewer, for me, it
acts as an invitation to
stay and look at that object.
And so by breaking
my expectations
of the ceramic objects, it just
holds my attention a little bit
longer.
I enjoy that choice.
And then it sort of trails
through and leaves its mark
around the whole project.
So thank you for that.
Thank you.
I see that Maddie
has her hand raised.
Awesome.
I think we have also
questions in the chat.
Hi.
I'm wondering if you can
talk a little bit about kind
of the process of
how you developed
the different materials
that you used.
It looks like there's a lot
of different types of clay
and different
materials you used.
Can you talk about,
like, where you
started in the
process of deciding
which of those were helpful--
Started with Graham, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
Graham's clay donations to us.
At first, we had very little
understanding of clay,
the material itself.
And so before even
starting this project,
we just ended up signing up
for the ceramics class up at SA
and actually learning a
little bit about how to--
like more traditional pottery
techniques and hand building
and wheel throwing.
And we realized that there's
this insanely broad and diverse
world of different
clay materials.
It's not like there's one kind
of clay or ceramic material.
It's just a huge range
of things that each
have their specific qualities.
And a lot of these objects
depend on those qualities
to become what they are.
And not only the
actual raw material,
but also how moist
it is and how it's
mixed to compose these objects
was a huge part of this study.
And I think that's also why you
see these objects especially
kind of showcased all the
different materials that we
tested.
And I think it's still
an open exploration,
because they definitely lead
to such different outcomes.
Yeah.
And also-- yeah, we wanted to
reiterate that the complexity
is in the material more than
the machines themselves,
because there are a lot of--
when we were researching some
other type of clay extruder
designs, the consensus
is that the difficulty
is in getting the clay
consistent, meaning,
like, it wasn't the problem
with the machines themselves.
It was a problem with the way
that we handled the material.
And the material is, like, so--
it can be so broad.
Clay, if you start
dissecting it,
is a combination of a
lot of different things.
Yeah.
And so when we took
the class at Harvard,
we were also very curious, can
we mix glass pieces into it?
Can we use the fired pieces
broken down into smaller pieces
and what they called
grog, I guess?
Can we incorporate
that into giving us
this, like, very smooth texture
versus a very rough texture?
Like, for example,
these are very smooth,
because the grains are fine.
And this one, for example, we
had, like, paper clay in it--
like, paper clay--
paper fibers in it.
So when it's extruding
from the same extruder,
you get this very
different qualities.
And so those are
still open questions.
Mm-hmm.
And I think the design
of that material
is, like, a critical thing
that's at the heart of this.
Totally.
Great.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
I see that we also have
a question from Carla.
Do you think it goes against
the machine's essence
in not being exact?
And how could that redefine
how we use machinery?
I think it's not going
against machines as a sense
in not being exact.
Machines have always been
inexact in the tolerance.
So the tolerance has been
getting smaller every iteration
of the machine designs.
But essentially,
how much error can
you tolerate is the
question rather than
the machine being exact.
Machines have--
there was this, like,
really interesting
reading from--
I forgot the guy's
name, but Ken Graham?
No.
I forgot the
author's name, but he
was discussing how the
most complex aircraft
parts were actually made--
hammered by these craftsmen
when the machines were
failing to produce, like,
the super precise geometry.
The craftsmen were
able to see it.
And actually, through
looking at their reflections,
they were able to discern it way
better than the machines could
do.
So this is of like,
we're trying to say
machines are never that exact.
Like, it's a conception
that we have.
It's a conception that the
building should be exact
that we want to dismantle.
And I don't think it's
going against a sense.
We're trying to
blend the essence.
Back to Tiandra's
other question about
if there's something
to be learned
by a sculptor or potter.
I guess we kind of
semi answered that
by saying that that's
where we started.
And we're not very
good at it yet.
But we're hoping to get
back to it once, I guess,
ceramics facilities reopen.
But I think there's
definitely a lot of exchange
to be made there.
And we actually, as part
of the Harvard classes,
I think-- and also maybe that
could be a really cool thing
to have at MIT as well.
But the ceramics artists
have been working with robots
and working with
architecture students like us
and sort of building that
exchange between the two
disciplines and two very
different ways of thinking
or making.
And I think bringing
those together--
there's a really cool
opportunity for that.
Yeah.
Totally.
I mean, we can't
emphasize how much
we learned before we even began
this from the clay classes
that we took at MIT.
Mm-hmm.
Shout out to Stacy.
Exactly.
Ooh, all right.
Here we go.
Andrea, our esteemed
CAMIT director,
says that she is a great
admirer of this project
because of how it
complicates the relationship
between the hand and the
machine and also because it's
one of the first
projects that she's
been able to follow
to fruition that
was funded by a CAMIT grant.
Could you reflect
on how that grant
helped you extend beyond where
your thesis work stopped?
And also, everybody,
there's a CAMIT plug.
So please do check out
the link in the chat.
I think we had
lots of plans for--
and, like, great
opportunities also
for doing something
very different from what
we had in mind initially.
And so as we were--
we were actually about to go
to another facility in March
when--
and we did, I think, one shop
training when MIT closed,
and everything else closed.
And that facility
still hasn't reopened.
So I think we ended up just--
the little time that
we had before that,
we worked on similar--
I think all of the larger
things that we made
and the things in
the studies room
were part of the
exploration that we began.
But that was, I think,
only one or two months
after we graduated.
And then all of our
plans were kind of
canceled by COVID closures.
And we actually started
working on simulations
and working with this
digital materiality of things
when we started talking
with Sarah and Heidi
about maybe moving the gallery
to this virtual space, which
ended up being, like, a really
rich and different format that
is inherently a part
of this project.
But it's always
in the background.
It's always kind of hidden.
And throughout this--
I guess thanks to having
this time when we're not
making that many
things, we had the time
to think about representing
them and turning them
into this different
kind of experience.
Yeah.
I mean, also in
terms of the grant,
we were able to make
much more brave choices
in terms of how the
direction of our thesis
was going to go based on
this opportunity that we got.
And had we not had the
grant, for example,
we wouldn't have been brave
enough to say, let's try
and make our own machine.
You know?
No.
Yeah.
And so it was definitely--
gave us the launching
pad for all of our--
Yeah, I think already
as part of our thesis,
we were kind of preparing
for this exhibition.
We always-- we had that in mind.
And that's why we already
had some of our stands
that Sarah also mentioned
in the beginning.
We were kind of ready to
move into the gallery.
But it's still in
there, I think.
[LAUGHS]
And it allowed us to go much
bigger in scale and much braver
in terms of designing
machines or displays.
And we're really
thankful for that.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
I just wanted to say thank
you so much for having us.
And I think tomorrow we'll also
have some really great events.
So thank you all for coming out.
And join Arts on the
Radar tomorrow too.
Yeah.
Thank you so much, everyone.
I would love to echo that.
Thank you all for attending.
Thank you to my co-host Sarah.
Thank you to Dalma and Jung.
Thank you for
everybody in the Office
of the Arts for their
fantastic, rock star support.
It was a long couple
of hours tonight,
but it was full of so
much great programming.
I'm really proud of everybody.
It's been a great kickoff
to Arts on the Radar.
Like Dalma said, please be
sure to come back and check out
our other panels and
workshops tomorrow.
And, like Sarah said, if you're
interested in any upcoming
events in the Wiesner, including
exhibition opportunities,
please follow the
link in the chat.
And have a fantastic
evening, everybody.
We'll see you all tomorrow.
Thank you.
Great job, Shannon.
Thanks so much.
Thank you, Dalma.
Thank you, Jung.
Bye!
Beautiful work, guys.
Thank you.